[Musique]
élégance grâce force et surtout
performance les enchaînements des
athlètes se succédent avec un objectif
s'approcher de la perfection et pour
cause samedi Fontenay-le-Fleury
Saint-Cyr-l'École accueillait les
finales nationales UFOLEP un enjeu de
taille pour les meilleurs athlètes de
France présents pour remporter le
dernier titre de la saison les
championnats c'est la fin de saison
voilà il y a eu trois compétitions avant
les départements les régionaux les
demi-finales les meilleurs sont là c'est
le rendez-vous de fin de saison
incontournable que tout le monde attend
qui a été compliqué à mettre en place
cette saison mais voilà c'est vraiment
le gros événement tout ça vient de
partout en France on a à peu près 2000
gymnastes on a près de 200 clubs qui
sont représentés au programme de cette
finale masculine et féminine 6 épreuves
pour les garçons parmi elles seules
arceau saut ou encore bar fixe autant
d'agréer aux figures aussi
spectaculaires que maîtrisées
[Applaudissements]
seul on a été un peu surpris par le par
le sol qui est gonflable mais ça c'est
quand même bien passé puis après arçon
on a fait ce qu'on savait se faire et à
nos pareils côté fille quatre agrès
barres asymétriques sol poutres et saut
et chacune c'est spécialités
alors c'est mon ingrat du tout on va
dire le sol aussi et la règle que les
barres on est tombé on a chuté donc
forcément c'est moins bien malgré
quelques chutes et une blessée dans
l'équipe cette compétition reste une
fierté pour ses yvelinoises c'était nos
championnats de France en équipe pour la
première fois donc c'était quand même
très sympa l'occasion de se confronter
au meilleur niveau et d'achever la
saison sous les regards émerveillés du
public et exigeant des juges l'équipe de
Lucie et Céliane terminale à la 7e place
de leur catégorie 12 équipes yvelinoise
étaient engagées elle ramène une
médaille d'or une d'argent et de deux
bronze en individuel 74 athlètes
yvelinois ont fait le déplacement ils
obtiennent deux médailles d'or et 3 en
bronze rendez-vous l'année prochaine
pour de nouveaux championnats